Good.
So let's do, then,
our transitions.
So we do the constant
perturbation.
Constant perturbation.
So as we said, delta
H is equal to V,
and it's time independent.
It just begins at time 0.
And we'll examine what's
going on by time t0.
So what are we going to do?
We're going to
examine a transition
to go from some initial
state i, initial state,
to a final state f.
So we don't have to say much
about what the Hamiltonian is
or anything.
For us, V is going
to have a constant.
It's going to have
some matrix elements
that once we do an
example you can calculate,
but for the time being we
need not know too much.
So I'm going to
use the key formula
that was derived already
about perturbation theory
and how you get the
transition amplitude.
So we know that the coefficient
c associated to the m state
to first order in
perturbation theory
at that time t0 can be computed
as a sum over all n integral
from 0 to t0 e to the i omega
mn t prime delta Hmn t prime
over ih bar Cn 0 dt prime.
So let me just say a few words.
You may have seen this
yesterday in recitation.
Here it is.
The state has described
in this usual language
of psi tilde of t was described
as a sum of c ms of ts ms.
And we calculate those
in perturbation theory.
So Cn's, we know them
at time equals 0,
we imagine we know
the initial state
and we want to
calculate them later.
Well, the first order
in perturbation theory,
the Cn's are called Cn's 1's.
And they're given
by this formula.
First order in
perturbation theory,
because we have
a single delta H,
this omega mn is the energy
of m minus the energy
of n over h bar.
And that's it.
Those are all our symbols.
So what do we have to do now?
We have a transition from some
initial state to a final state.
So what does that mean?
It means that Cn 0,
it only exists when
n represents the initial state.
So I'll just write delta ni.
At time equals zero,
system is in the state i.
And at time t0, we're
asking for the probability
to go into final state.
So instead of using n and
m, we're just using f and i.
And therefore, we'll
have m equal f.
With these two
facts, the formula
becomes cf the amplitude to
first order in perturbation
theory to be in the state f
at time t0 is the sum is gone,
sum over n just
applies for n equals i.
So i will go here.
We'll have one over
ih bar 0 to t0 e
to the i omega final
state to initial state.
That's m and n t prime Vfi,
because the delta H is V,
and we're going from
initial to final.
So fi here.
And then the t prime.
It's all gone.
It's all become
very simple, though.
You would say too simple.
We have this is
time independent,
so it goes out of the interval.
So we just have the interval
of an exponential here.
That's very, very easy.
What is Vfi case vi?
So
This goes out, and we just have
to integrate this function.
I'll write it in a
way that is simpler.
Maybe you skip a line.
I don't want to just
count the factors of is
and doing the integral.
When you integrate this,
you get another exponential.
You're going to get
the exponential at t0
minus the exponential at zero.
All right, so we don't
want to do our integral.
So I'll just write the answer.
I was saying we get
an exponential here
at t0 minus the
value at zero, then
you take half of the
exponential out the form a sign.
This are simple matters, so I
will not do the integral here.
You get Vfi over Ef
minus Ei e to the i omega
fi t0 two minus two i sine
of omega fi t0 over two.
You can believe that.
I think you can
believe the sine,
and I have everything here.
The h bar helped turn the
omega fi into Ef minus Ei.
So we can now compute the
transition probability
to go from the initial
to the final stage.
So we'll write it like this.
I to f-- it's a little funny.
I don't know.
You can write it
whichever way you want.
Some people like it like that.
I'm going to do it in the sense
that the initial state always
appears as a cat, the
final state as a bra.
So you draw the arrow
like that, more or less
to keep the sense of
order in your brain.
But if it doesn't
help you, write it
whichever way you want.
Pfi at t0 one is
the norm squared
of this coefficient, cf one.
The probability to be
found in the final state
has to do with the norm
squared of this thing.
So it's this that's part of what
was reviewed yesterday squared.
So what do we get?
That simplifies quite a bit.
We get Vfi squared times
four sine squared omega fi
t0 over two over ef
minus ei squared.
And this is unit free.
This has units of energy.
V is a variation
of the Hamiltonian.
It has units of energy.
When you put states,
states are normalized
so it doesn't change the units.
And this has units of energy
squared, this has no units,
and this is the answer.
A little strange.
There's a periodic variation
on the transition probability,
and what does it mean to
have a weak perturbation we
can ask already?
And the answer in
general is quite simple.
It's a pragmatic answer.
A perturbation is
weak if this answer
is very little, very small.
Suppose this probability
comes out to be three,
you know it's already too big.
But if this is 10 to the minus
sixth times this function,
that's reasonable.
You're shining atoms
and one in a million
goes and gets ionized.
That's a reasonable thing.
So the perturbation theory
is valid for whatever time
you use this formula as long
as this number is small,
and this could be arranged by
having Vfi sufficiently small.
I want to understand
this function better,
because this is a transition
from initial state
to final state that
looks like that.
So let's understand it better.
Suppose one, Ef is different
from Ei, then how does it look?
Well, it looks like this.
I brought some other chalk
not that it helps too much.
But it looks like this
as a function of time.
The height here
is height four Vfi
squared over Ef minus Ei
squared, and it's oscillatory.
It goes to zero again at
time 2 pi over omega fi.
OK, so this is the oscillation.
Actually for a small time,
this grows quadratically,
and then it starts blowing up.
So here while the
initial behavior
would be quadratic
for small time,
this actually is quadratic
as we will see in a second,
but you can more or less see
by the expansion of the sine,
then the initial quadratic
growth gets tamed and becomes
an oscillation here.
This is valid for all times if
this number is relatively small
so that we believe
perturbation theory,
and that's that for that case.
It's also interesting
that this gets suppressed
as the energy of the final
state is different, more
and more different, from the
energy of the initial state.
So it always oscillates, but
if the state your transition
is very far away, it is going
to be extremely suppressed
by the quadratic factors.
So this is an
important suppression.
This is saying that transitions
that change the energy
are not that favored.
A constant perturbation
doesn't supply really
energy to produce transitions
that change the energy much,
and they are suppressed.
So they produce them,
but they are suppressed.
The other case
that is of interest
is the case when
Ef is equal to Ei.
I'm not saying that the state
f is the same as the state i.
Not at all.
It's a different
state but happens
to have the same energy,
and in that case,
we must take the
limit as Ef goes
to Ei, remember omega fi is
Ef minus Ei so over h bar.
So the limit as ef goes to
Ei of this Pif is how much.
I'll kind of do it
in my head here.
We have an h bar here that
is going to be left over.
One over h bar,
so h bar squared.
This is going to cancel.
The four is going
to cancel with this,
and we're going
to get vfi squared
over h squared t0 squared.
OK, so here it is,
the quadratic behavior
when the energy
of the final state
is the same as the energy
of your original state.
Now, the transition probability
starts to grow quadratically.
That cannot be valid
for too long time,
because eventually that
number grows without bound,
and that number could
become as big as 1,
and that transition
is not reasonable.
So this is valid
up to some max t0.
And it's up to you,
depends on what Vfi is,
how long you can trust this.
So this is a growth.
This is the same
growth we observe here.
The limit as Ef goes
to Ei go to zero
is actually the same as the
limit as t goes to zero,
so it's the same
quadratic behavior.
So finally, what's
going to happen?
What are we aiming here?
Well, we're aiming
to the case where
we have in the energy line,
we have the initial energy Ei
and then we're going to have
a continuum of final states
that overlap with Ei.
They're all over there.
That's Ef all over there.
Of course with our box, if
you come with your microscope,
you see lines here.
But they're all there.
There is a continuum
overlapping with this,
and now we're going to attempt
to sum over the continuum.
And what should we observe?
We should observe that
when we add the continuum
physically, what do we need?
We need to find what is called
a transition rate, in which you
have the probability of
transition per unit time
is a constant.
You see, you have
a phenom-- you're
shining light on an atom.
OK, you shine
light and you wait.
Eventually the atom ionizes--
photoelectric effect.
But if you have a billion
atoms, then you can shine light
and you're going to have a
transition rate, basically how
many atoms are going
to happen to ionize.
So in order to have
a transition rate,
the probability
that you transition
has to be proportional
to the time
that the perturbation
has been acting.
So the probability of transition
must grow linear in t.
Therefore, you have
a transition rate
which is the probability of
transition per unit time,
so you can grow linear
in time, so per unit time
you have a transition rate.
So somehow look
what's happening here.
When Ef is different than Ei,
the transition probability
is not linear in time.
It does this.
When E approaches--
Ef approaches Ei, the
probability of transition
goes quadratic in
time, and what we want
is a probability of transition
that grows linear in time.
That would define
a transition rate.
So how is that going to happen?
Well, we'll see it happen
in front of our eyes.
The magic of integration
is going to do it.
And moreover, we're
going to see that
consistent with this intuition,
most of the transitions
that are relevant are happening
within Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle of a little energy
interval here around Ei.
So this will be considered to
be at the end of the day energy
conserving transitions.
The Hamiltonian, the delta V
helps the transition happen
but doesn't supply energy
at the end of the day.
So this is what
we're getting to.